[Music]
let's
go now to philip rycroft he was
permanent secretary of the department
of exiting the eu philip welcome to
the spectator tv was it always going to
be this difficult
not necessarily it's not surprising that
it's been quite
tough and this is it's an important
relationship for both sides probably
the most important relationship
certainly on trade but also
on issues like internal security and so
on
so there's a huge amount to play for but
of course we have these big arguments of
principle
which are causing the blockage now and
that's has been described already
on the one hand the uk saying we left in
order to be able to set our own rules
on the other side the eu saying you want
privileged access to our market
obligations come with that in the way
that you manage your own
regulatory environment but since this
is now even if we get a deal it looks
like it's going to be a
pretty skinny deal it's not going to be
this canada plus plus that we were
talking about nearby may not even be
canada we
we've been calling it canada dry um on
this
if it is so skinny why is the eu
insisting that we remain aligned
in so many ways with whatever the eu
does
well it is in in contrast to
being in the single market it's a skinny
deal but as a trade deal
it would be one of the more advanced
that the eu has done
particularly of course on tariff and
quotas that would be the big win
no tyrosine quotas for uk
businesses trading with the eu and vice
versa and the eu side has said all along
through this and this isn't a new
position
and you're not like canada you're a lot
closer you do a lot more trade with us
and we are therefore commensurately
more worried about you trading unfairly
with us that's the position they've
taken
we have to remember that the single
market is essentially a jewel in the eu
crown the legal construct that gives
life and meaning to being a member
of the eu which is why they protect it
so fiercely
the eu as a construct is designed to
look after the interests
of its own member states not of third
parties and that's
hence the caution in seeking to strike a
deal with a close and important trading
partner like the uk
so when it came to the free trade deal
with canada
and although that was not entirely
tariff-free or entirely quotas
it was a pretty uh a lot of stuff the
tariffs came away and the quarters
came away it was a pretty decent as free
trade deals go
this was a pretty decent and extensive
free trade deal
the eu did not insist that canada's
state subsidy regime had to fall in line
with the eu
although there had to be dynamic
alignment of canada's rules and
regulations
with the eu i think a lot of british
people won't understand
why you insist yeah well we're closer
but so what
uh most of our economy is services and
services are not
geo-specific um they won't understand
why the british are being treated
differently from the canadians
sure obviously that's been a big part of
the arguments all the way through this
and the the
assumption on in on many people's part
that the eu is being
unreasonable away from the you looked at
from where we are now we are now a third
country
that we want this privileged access to
their market
uh of course the the eu is perfectly
free sovereign if you like to set the
conditions
for that and i come back to the point
the concern
as i understand it i don't speak for the
eu clearly
is because of the proximity and
proximity
still matters in trade terms and because
of the volume of trade
that they worry about the the uk
stealing a a march on eu-based
businesses by
allowing a different set of standards to
emerge either side of the channel
but the eu runs a massive trade surplus
well actually runs a
overall uh current account surplus with
the uk
but it particularly runs a massive trade
surplus in traded goods
uh with the with the uk it would have to
be one hell of a change in britain's
rules and
regulations to den that very much i mean
this is not a straw man
well i i wonder actually from both sides
of the
of this argument whether in three or
four years time particularly if we land
up with no deal we'll look back and
think
what was all that fuss about and if you
if you think about it
exactly your point it would take some
really big divergence in standards
to have a material impact on trading
conditions
but if you look at it from a uk
perspective the government's already
said we accept non-regression so we're
not going to lower
existing standards and if you think of
things like environment the government
they're keen to push on
on climate change so improving standards
is a good thing
and even if our standards are somewhat
different from the eu's
uh when you roll forward five ten years
time
it seems very likely that the eu and the
uk will still be
running similar levels of standards
because that's what developed mature
civilized modern economies will do
the one thing that stands out of that of
course is state aid
where the uk has been very insistent uh
on freedom to spend more money
supporting businesses
paradoxically because it's always been
the uk that has been the biggest
proponent
of control of state aid at the eu level
and france and germany within the rule
still spend
a lot more money on state aid than the
uk does
and so one again has to question the
motivations there
i mean i speak as somebody who was a
civil servant for 30 odd years worked
quite a lot on the business side of
things the state at the end of the day
is generally not the best place to
determine
um you know which are the winners in the
future economy
in other words the uk moving into a
position where it wants to splash
a lot of taxpayers cash around on
businesses sort of
shades of the 1970s and british leyland
there and i wonder again in three or
four years time where people will look
back and say
you know wasn't that a bit of a red
herring to a point another phrase so the
fisheries i think we can sort out by the
way
uh i i never thought i would uh see a
stumbling block for a tory government to
be
the the right to dole out lots of state
aid
has there been have these talks from the
start phillip
been characterized by a certain
mutual mutual incomprehension
yes i and i think also a lack of trust
and i think that lack of trust has been
there um
all the way through but was exacerbated
of course by the uk internal market bill
happily now those clauses uh that
offended the eu and indeed other
international partners have now
have now been withdrawn but i think
there has been this mutual
incomprehension on the eu side what has
driven brexit
and from the uk side a misunderstanding
of how the eu operates and where
the deep concerns of the eu lie and
and that's just not been very helpful um
throughout all of this
and is perhaps a signal also of the way
in which
the uk through our membership um never
really got sort of integrated into
understanding the operation of the eu
uh in a way that's second nature to uh
to the the countries of are
more core to that enterprise if we were
to leave on
no deal would the in your view would
there then
quite quickly by that i mean sometime
next year maybe
after the summer would there be a move
then to try and reopen
the talks and do a free trade deal again
try and get that done
or would would relations actually
both sides may be so angry that
relations could end up in the freezer
for quite
some time yeah three quick things to say
about that one is
um that the eu and the uk will have to
talk about
stuff from here on forever whether we
like it or not
including fisheries common resource the
fish
don't respect the median line they don't
get spawned as a british or a french
fish
the stocks move around you have to
manage these resources in common
and there'll be loads of other stuff
where we have to talk second point
uh this relationship is too important
both on trade and on internal security
and on a bunch of other things
not to formalize the relationship at
some point
but third point i agree with you with
you when you say that the
risk is if we have no deal at the end of
this year tempers will be such and
political pride will be such
that neither side will be willing to be
the one that says oh
we need to get first we need to get back
round the table
so it could be some time before
negotiations resume to put the
relationship on a sound footing
when you stand back a little bit from
trying to work out whether we're going
to get a deal or
no deal and get away from the incredible
detail that goes in
to these talks uh whether you were for
remain
or whether you were for leave when you
look at uh
how close the eu in the uk how many
areas we will need to cooperate in the
2020s
and beyond our common interests as well
in or out
of the you know it's our biggest market
we have a common interest
in the eurozone doing well whether we're
in the eu or not
in defense and security and intelligence
and let me just standing up for
democracy
and human rights we have all so much in
common
we we are free traders you know we don't
want
tariffs if we can is it if we don't get
a deal
is it not really depressing that two
sides with so much in common
just couldn't do a bloody trade deal yes
and and actually a failure of statecraft
on both sides after four and a bit years
not to be able to manage that and let's
not even know the deal that's on the
table as you described it earlier it's
quite a thin
deal no deal is damaging it's
economically damaging
for both sides the application of
tariffs in terms of automotives
agri-food and so on even for fisheries
is very damaging
all the other agreements fall away like
on internal security
on research and all the rest of it even
australia
i know that people talk about australia
as the no deal destination
even australia has a number of deals
with the eu we would only have
one the withdrawal agreement uh if you
think about short-term disruption at the
border in an ideal world
what is the incentive on the part of the
eu authorities or the french authorities
the belgian authorities to play nice but
just one final thought on this which is
i think hugely important
for the uk we've got some really rather
important elections coming up next year
uh in scotland and wales and we know
where opinion is at in scotland
on the question of independence we know
that brexit
and and feeling about brexit in scotland
has been a bit of a driver for that and
no deal
brexit uh it seems to me exacerbates
concern
within the uk union about our future
direction as a country
and somebody lives in scotland and a lot
of work in scotland
that worries me immensely well you used
to work in government in scotland so
let's finish on scotland because
if you look at what it's taken and we're
not
there yet to unravel a 50-year
arrangement um which wasn't it despite
what a lot of the brexit has said in
many areas wasn't that deep
i mean what is it and we're still four
years out and we've still not left yet
or even come to a deal if scotland was
to vote for independence in a second
referendum
i mean the mind boggles of what these
negotiations would require
unraveling 300 years of
union and a country's economies
cultures peoples who have been totally
integrated everywhere you think i mean
they're not going to happen very quickly
either
no in a word i absolutely agree with
that and we sort of peered over that uh
cliff edge back in 2014 when the
referendum on scottish independence came
quite close
of course of course notoriously the
prime minister of the day david cameron
didn't allow us within whitehall to do
any contingency planning
um for that eventuality but um what i
can say is behind the scenes
particularly after that famous sunday
times poll
that put the yes side ahead there was a
bit of uh
scurrying around in the in the corridors
of whitehall to think
how on earth do we cope literally on day
one
of that result but you're absolutely
right and we did a huge amount of work
describing
uh the benefits of the uk union for all
parts of the union
uh we had about 14 or 15 times from
everything from defense
um through to the social security system
to culture
to movement of people and so on
dismantling all of that
uh would be an absolutely huge
challenge and would be for the british
state
for the remainder uk would be a
distraction
from everything else that you wish to do
for for
for years um we when we when brexit
happened
uh of course again we didn't we didn't
do a lot of contingency planning
for that either but we know from the
experience there
just what a massive task that was which
started the day after the referendum
and is far from finite finish now and
but scottish independence would make all
of that pale
in comparison the ryecroft was that
thought
and the mind boggles we'll leave it
there we thank you for your time and
expertise
uh being on spectator tv and we wish you
a very merry christmas
and you thank you very much
[Music]
you